hey what's going on and still burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 22nd 2016 what's going on oh
yeah
once again I got a computer issues here
that I got to get fixed when I get back
to Los honglei's I am in in Seattle
Seattle Washington right now which I got
to tell you man if you come to Seattle
in May or June when the Sun is out it's
like you want to live here it really is
one of the most beautiful cities in the
United States if you can just deal with
overcast skies from like October through
April and these people pay the price but
when the Sun comes out it's [ __ ]
unbelievable so I'm here with Nate Craig
who's been crushing it this whole
[ __ ] tour and we just went out to get
some eats like a couple of tourists we
go you want to go down to the fisherman
place where they're throwing the fish
and everything so like yes we start
walking down there and of course it's
mobbed and I say to him ago you realize
that nobody from Seattle [ __ ] goes
down here you know unless they're on
like a first date or you know your dad
and mom are taking you down there to go
see it but I would think that you would
avoid it so we didn't go all the way
down and we just kind of kept walking we
got a little bit when we walked along
that main drag we just got a little bit
away from it and after wading into that
sea of [ __ ] humanity I was literally
like dude I will eat mediocre food if I
don't have to stand in the line I can
actually sit down like a human being I
know the food is good but I just don't
understand you standing there like a
[ __ ] bread line like it's the middle
of a war or some [ __ ]
alright you live in the United States of
America we don't stand in [ __ ] line
for food we wall our fat asses up you
just hand it to me
so I'm not going to name the place but I
went to this place it was it was halfway
the bread [ __ ] stunk you know to me
how do you make [ __ ] king crab only
taste okay you know while you have
shitty bread other than that it was uh
it's definitely a good time and such a
beautiful city despite all the dirty
white people up here there's a major
[ __ ] you know I'm gonna avoid using
the word crunch I think that was just a
nice way of just stick [ __ ] there is
some dirty [ __ ] white people up here
I don't I don't understand it
just there in Denver those are the the
two filthiest white people that actually
have money like you you have too much
money to be that filthy like when you go
to Denver is those [ __ ] dreadlocks
like man sandal wear and egg always
looking like you just got off a [ __ ]
one of those blowup tubes you know
smoking your [ __ ] weed whatever the
whatever they're doing out there
you know hairy armpit type of [ __ ] worse
than San Francisco I don't mind any of
those styles if you babe means 2016
Jesus Christ
um okay and it's like they're like which
is probably just me being an old man I
can't honestly say none of them smelled
but they just they look like you know
you wouldn't want to borrow anything
that they used why am i starting off as
me I started off so nice I was saying
how beautiful is it stretch up the
layout of the city is [ __ ] perfect
and they even with their new stadiums
that they made like I actually am old
school as far as I loved it back when
they just had the Kingdome you know and
they had that great like the Seattle
SuperSonics had like you know that the
skyline I know that they had the Space
Needle I believe they had the Kingdome
there unless it was supposed to be key
arena I have no idea but those two
arenas were and are two of the coolest
places ever I saw a Seattle SuperSonics
game there the last year they were there
in with Kevin Durant's first year
somewhere I don't know I have a picture
of him in the Seattle Seahawks csefel
super Seattle Sonics I should say
uniform and then back in the day when I
was just doing call
College gigs traveling the road by
myself driving a Chrysler Chrysler k-car
this I went to a game Seattle Mariners
game at the Kingdome and ken griffey jr.
was still on the team how long ago was
like the late 90s possibly early 2000 I
forget when he went to the Ritz but I
deliberately I bought us one single
centerfield seat and I got almost like
the front row I think I was the second
row and this is some sports fan Dikshit
i sat there it's not only did I want to
watch Griffey play but I also wanted to
like every night on SportsCenter
whenever they showed a game at the
Kingdome and somebody hit a homerun
there was like this weird little runway
like Iowa you see people chasing after
the ball and I wanted the opportunity to
to do that which I did all by myself I
didn't get the [ __ ] ball and so
whatever um but having said all that if
you ever visit Seattle in May or June
and it's all sunny and you're like oh my
god I could live here make sure you come
back in like January or December or
someone of those [ __ ] you know I
understand Kurt Cobain now one of those
months but anyways we're we're
performing there tonight I'm recording
this podcast Sunday afternoon because uh
I got to get back and go back to the
writers room working on Episode five
everybody five out of number ten and
once we get this one done it's all
downhill from there yeah we're excited
about this episode and I don't know I'm
hoping you guys are going to like it but
anyways so big thank you to everybody
who came out to Edmonton last night and
went out to Calgary Calgary might have
been the best sound I've ever heard at a
show I was standing backstage and make
Craig was on stage I mean the backstage
Aaron usually in most venues when you're
standing to the side of the stage you
can barely understand the person just
the way the
sound is bouncing around I'm sure it's
fine in the house but like you know so
many times they'll be with bartnick or
Burgi or something then literally just
be like dude you hit that new biddat but
I did about blah blah blah I was like I
was trying to but I couldn't quite hear
it because of the sound I was standing
almost like directly behind where Bob
and behind the curtain when Nate was
onstage and I could hear the guy
absolutely perfectly and he was just
like I was [ __ ] awesome it was just a
great gig both of the gigs and then the
next day you know we got up we drove up
to Edmonton which believe it or not I've
done that drive like three times and
just beautiful beautiful [ __ ] country
up in Canada absolutely gorgeous I would
go out of my [ __ ] mind I think if I
did the road enough so if I just flew to
other places then I could come back
that's how I really view all these
places you know that it considered the
middle of nowhere they're like these
paradises what I think I would lose my
mind if all I did was live out there
like I understand the people when they
come up to you they're like oh my god I
want to get out of here you know this is
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and I'm
always you know coming from LA where
everybody's living on top of each other
and we have no water and [ __ ] I'm like
dude you are living in the Garden of
Eden okay this is as good as it gets as
far as Natural Resources four seasons
and that type of [ __ ] although what's
cold as [ __ ] when we were up there it
for me anyways I mean the last night in
Edmonton was actually Sweeting I think
crazy but um we ended up driving
obviously up to Edmonton and that night
at the gig this might have been the
weirdest [ __ ] venue I've played in a
long time it was essentially I took a
picture of it it was essentially a giant
tent that had a little bit of an upper
deck in the back and there was no
carpeting like behind me they didn't he
had all this [ __ ] equipment for the
lights and everything and they usually
they dress it up they put a curtain
there so people don't have to look at it
but they didn't it was like this giant
eyesore behind me and I was standing on
this concrete slab that had no no
carpeting no nothing the floor was all
concrete they just had chairs the sides
of the walls I know what they were made
of all I know it was I was on stage I
felt like I was like screaming in a
giant garage like I it seemed loud to me
but I couldn't tell if it was loud I
didn't see anybody complain well like my
ears are kind of ringing today and I got
a couple of tweets people were saying
like like dude you sounded like you were
yelling into a megaphone into a
microphone so my apologies there were
somebody mentioned something on one of
the shows I would have toned it down
with sometimes when you're up there you
can hear yourself but I ended up I sent
a picture to Mia and now I can assure to
had the tweeted a message she sent me
the text that she sent me she said that
looks like a venue where one of those
those fake televangelist you know you
have plants in the crowd and they go to
like Purim and [ __ ] and I'll post the
picture of it then as always our sale
[ __ ] do it then I know they do but
I'll try to do it this time you know
what whatever if you follow the MMP on
on [ __ ] on Twitter maybe it'll be up
there I have no idea but before I go any
further uh I forgot to mention on the
all things comedy Network is really
doing well I'm a terrible businessman I
never bring it up but um we've got some
people to invest in it when you start
creating to a more con content and that
type of stuff and you know really try to
and I'll join forces with other comics
and hopefully make some comments some
money off of that thing and get you guys
some good comedy everybody works we keep
the big [ __ ] out of the way you know
or very least you know keep them from
taking the rights of everybody's [ __ ]
shows you know that always seems to be
like the business plan like okay yeah
we'll invest alright we own everything
you work for us you go [ __ ] yourself
we'll sleep in bed and make mailbox
money and you'll be on the road when
you're 90 sound good no it doesn't well
it's going to be good exposure will be I
would say any young comics out there
anytime anybody tries to pay you an
exposure any time they say it's good
closure that means you're getting [ __ ]
[Music]
all right also this Thursday I'm doing a
charity show this Thursday 8 p.m. at the
Comedy Store 100% of the money goes
towards helping children who are
fighting cancer to have as normal of
childhood as possible while they're
going through the treatment and all that
the tickets are available at the Comedy
Store after show we'll put up a link for
anyone who can't make it if they want to
donate Steve Simone puts the thing
together and he's been doing great
things and my comics go to hospitals and
stuff like that this is a charity that I
can get behind which brings me back to
the mysterious Red Nose campaign so a
bunch of people were looking into that
found it very vague and now I guess it
helps out poor children that's why you
have the clown noses which is hilarious
to me because I think it's pretty much
mainstream knowledge that clowns kind of
scare the [ __ ] out of most children and
a lot of adults I just don't understand
why you got to have the stupid clown
nose what are you going to do with that
[ __ ] thing other than just throw it
out and it's going to be you know it's
going to end up in the [ __ ] ocean and
then back into fish to eat
it's so [ __ ] dumb like it's not
enough to just say listen we are helping
out poor children do people still say
nuts I don't want to do that you got to
be like well what if we give your little
red nose he knows you're like okay
that's such a good idea it's such like a
[ __ ] and I think it's like a hacky
cherry thing it all started with the
things the age rhythm was the first
thing or was it the quilt and then came
the Lance Armstrong LIVESTRONG thing
right and I don't know somewhere in
there with the super finger I have no
[ __ ] I don't I don't pretend to know
these things anyways what am i living I
let my mail this [ __ ] new thing is
driving me nuts I'm so used to not
having to look at these [ __ ] this
Garage Band [ __ ]
a resinize creepy thing it's really not
a nice creepy thing it's just sort of a
[ __ ] creepy thing so we rented this
car when we drove up from Calgary to
Phillips Edmonson from Calgary and we
had the thing actually picked it up at
the airport and um yeah we were driving
over to the casino that's what it was
driving over to casino and I find I just
look on the dashboard I'm like what the
[ __ ] is that what is that on the
download is that a camera I think it was
a camera and I think it was pointed it
up because there was nothing in the
front I don't know if it was the GPS
antenna I don't know what the [ __ ] it
was but it was really creepy
so of course through a [ __ ] newspaper
over the goddamn thing and when I got
back to the hotel I looked up about cars
and cameras and I found this article
here it says is your rental car company
spying on you and you're driving here's
how they do it all right
rental car giant Hertz has admitted it
is it has cameras installed in about one
in eight of its cars in the United
States but those cameras built into
Hertz is never lost dashboard assistant
that offers routing health and local
city guides have never been turned on
give me a [ __ ] really you spend all
that money and he never turned them on
you lyin [ __ ] purchase said loudly and
repeatedly they've never turned them on
understand that never law six was
launched by Hertz in early 2014 the
product has been out there for over a
year and only now is it causing flap
probably because most wrenches began
noticing a creepy camera pointed at them
understand too there are excellent
reasons to worry about car rental
companies Sparta
plumpie spying on drivers but very
probably never lost six is not one of
them first said it is last it is it
lacked the bandwidth to use the cameras
anyway but it's been so scorched but it
scorched so severely in a media flap of
the past weeks that industry experts
indicated that hurts now would be just
about the last company to spy on its
customers does any event make any sense
that you put a camera in there and then
you wouldn't use it you can still
a camera no we're just a little
mom-and-pop place we don't have the
[ __ ] bandwidth for it some of this
shit's funny they actually find some
people like hundreds sometimes thousands
of dollars using this [ __ ] and basically
you know when you rent a car and they go
okay you got to stay in the tri-state
area or you not leave in California
right some [ __ ] guy he ended up being
left California went to Nevada and then
Arizona and then they they gave him a I
don't know where the [ __ ] it was he
would slap with a bill three thousand
four hundred five dollars and five cents
by adding one dollar per mile to each of
the twenty eight seventy four miles
being driven because he had crap across
the California state line into Nevada to
me that's funny okay because that guy's
a piece of [ __ ] he lied to the car
company alright I'm not just saying
purchase a piece of [ __ ] people who buy
rental cars they treat them like [ __ ]
are also pieces of [ __ ] but to sit there
and film people and then you know
they're going to start recording
conversations you want to stand like in
the future
okay you go to run for president like
what could like bring you down is some
[ __ ] up thing you said some argument
you had in the car with some girlfriend
you're not even with twenty years
earlier and they just bring that up in
the middle of the debate like I think in
the future like they let it like once
you become a public figure they will
just have on a disk you know and it's
all going to be logged anything you ever
[ __ ] did like questionable [ __ ] good
[ __ ] that you did all the balance you
know they'll probably just have like a
pie chart okay here's his life disk you
know and the good stuff is in whatever
green or yellow man right all the nice
friendly [ __ ] colors and then the bad
[ __ ] will be all in like red
I don't you're prone to depression
they'll be like some blue in there and
they'll just look at the big pie chart
and try to judge it then overall what
kind of a [ __ ] person you are it's
just it's I know it's really creepy this
is another one that was funny to me it
says in in Florida rental car companies
are notorious for litter
shutting off engines of cars that cross
straight state lines the cars maybe
restart started upon agreement to pay
the new fees it's [ __ ] hilarious
here's my question how do you know
they're not in the left lane doing 90
miles an hour with somebody on that bump
are you just going to shut off the car
that you have to wait until the car
stops I would like to think that but I
don't know part of me I don't mind if
they track you with the GPS as far as
that and if you leave the state lines I
mean that's only fair you [ __ ] lying
to them and the technology exists but
that shift to start recording
conversations and videotaping you is
like I don't know man that really
crosses a line I don't know some people
say what about these [ __ ] texting
and driving there it did you know
they're killing people in type of [ __ ]
they have to be a better way what do you
guys think there's got to be a better
way to keep I mean I'm you know how safe
you have to make the world I mean
there's too many [ __ ] people can you
let some people die I mean I know that's
really morbid to say that [ __ ] but um I
don't know I'm kind of a [ __ ] up
person so why would you listen me why
would you listen to this podcast I know
what you're on your way to work you're
at the gym you whatever the [ __ ] you
doing so let's uh should we do oh man I
don't really bad bad little social faux
pas after the cavalry thing I was
walking over to the hotel and I was
trying to get into the elevator because
I was in the lobby
sometimes you go through the lobby you
know people want pictures and [ __ ] like
that which is cool but daddy wants to
drink so I was trying to get through
there as fast as I could and one of the
guys you know what that's it you know
one of the guys who worked at sort of
you know his elevator door opened and I
[ __ ] he did sort of told me to come
in I guess steps informing people and
walked on me and Nathan the promoter the
doors closed and as we was going up make
goes um did we just step in front of a
woman in a wheelchair waiting for an
elevator
and then add on them because I did fear
but I was in such a selfish moment of I
don't want to take any you know pictures
or anything I just want to get back down
because the bar was closing that's right
and you know we had a great night it's
nothing better after a show you're all
[ __ ] amped up from the excitement of
doing it and it went well that you can't
just go back to a hotel room go to sleep
you want to sit down shoot the [ __ ] or
whatever so we will that's right we will
make it a mad dash to get down to the
barber before clothes now that's a lie
they were actually keeping it open for
us there was really no reason for me to
do it other than my own selfish things I
didn't feel like they can a picture so I
ran in there and said it's been bugging
me for the last 48 [ __ ] hours mate
hurt or say something sad of Lloyd said
something well I guess we're not getting
on this one you know classic polite
Canadian so I don't know whatever
[ __ ] reason if you're the person
pushing the first in the wheelchair my
apologies old freckles was a selfish
[ __ ] there I'm literally getting
embarrassed telling the story right now
but that's that legitimately happened
and it was me I don't know if my rental
car company has video or audio of it you
know I'm getting out in front of the
stories what I'm doing alright enough of
that Big Brother [ __ ] let's now let's
read some advertising here for the week
MGMT watches when you're in your early
20s and 30s money can be tight if you're
not careful dressing well can quickly
drain your bank account like spending
400 to 500 dollars on a department store
watch there's some brand names out there
that are charging insane prices for
watches that aren't even remotely worth
it well if you want to look great when
you go out but still have enough money
to buy him or her a drink
check out movement watches dot-com
these watches are really Shep originally
founded by two broke college kids
movement washes cut the middleman out
and they're big brand retail markups in
order to give you a stylish watch that's
at an affordable price move and watch it
started just 95 bucks a watch with the
dust department store quality for a
fraction of the price
this sleek and minimalistic a modern
twist on a classic style movement has
grown organically purely by the
supporters like you so to join their
more than 1 million social media
followers and get a
watch today here's where you go go to
MGMT watches calm / / and they'll give
you 50% off your entire order that's m/v
Michael Vincent Michael Kengo watches
dot-com / / alright ah doc Dollar Shave
Club everybody
I love upset some of you truly are
that's actually dr. Carver's shea butter
it was easy shea butter but it's now
it's not easy anymore but it was always
dr. Carver's I just you know I have some
sort of that would kid I'm stupid you
know I was going to say some sort of
reading disabilities that's a cop-out
now don't be a [ __ ] built Dollar
Shave Club everybody's
dollarshaveclub.com as a special offer
for new members who join you'll get a
free month of the executive razor when
you buy a tube of dr. Carvey shea butter
I hate it I don't like it dr. cabbie
baby shea butter this is the first time
they've ever done something like this
and once you tried it
dollarshaveclub.com you'll become a
proud member like millions of others one
reason is because they deliver amazing
razors right to your door for third the
price of what the greedy razor
corporations charge that means when you
join Dollar Shave Club you can afford to
shave with a fresh blade anytime you
want which feels fantastic it just feels
amazing on your face you'll get a
first-class shave when use the executive
blade without hurting your wallet
another reason is the adopted child easy
is using it with the executive razor
makes the blade glide gently to this for
the smoothest shave ever dr. carver shea
butter isn't your average shave cream
its unique conditioning formula and the
hot with high-quality neutral
ingredients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth and right
now new members who buy a tube of shave
butter get the executive raises for free
they've never done this before everybody
take advantage of it and it's only
available by going to
dollarshaveclub.com slash fur that
dollarshaveclub.com slash / one more and
then we're done
dance calm everybody you know checks to
the post office are never convenient so
why get postage right why not get
postage right from your desk with
stamps.com stamps calm even off gives
you special postage discounts you can't
get at the post office including
first-class Priority Mail express
international and more you'll never pay
full price for postage again here's how
stamps Comics using your own computer
and printer you can buy and print
official US postage for any letter a
package then just hand your mail to the
mailman or drop it in a mailbox it's
that [ __ ] easy
no wonder over 600,000 small businesses
are already using stamps calm I use
fence Calm
anytime I'm selling posters whatever
horseshit I'm selling after the show if
I can figure out how to use it so can
you right now sign up defense calm and
use my last name / for this special
offer for week trial plus $110 bonus
offer that includes postage and a
digital scale scale don't wait get
started with stamps calm today go to
Stan's calm before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type of bird at Stan's
comm interfer there you go alright let
me get rid of this [ __ ] copier so I
can get on to the questions and all of
that [ __ ] by the way did anybody watch
game through a of the Saint Louie Louie
me yes I said they gave the [ __ ] Shaq
the oh right there Fred I'm not gonna
lie to you as a complete bandwagon fan
this is one of the biggest examples of
bandwagon fan [ __ ] you'll ever see is me
becoming a blue cent you know just
picking a team right and I after they
lost game two in game 3 and how great
the Sharks look I was just like I was
talking my buddy going like these guys
look like they're dialed in I think the
shops are going to win the whole [ __ ]
thing and it's just been such a weird
series like Game two three and four you
know like sharks dominated two and three
and then it's like they didn't even
[ __ ] show and don't like the Blues
didn't even show up games two and three
and I'm thinking like God the sharks got
to figure it out they're going to make
quick work of them and then the blue
show up last night it was like [ __ ]
two or three never happened so I can't
figure it out something on Twitter sent
me something saying these games have
sucked because they've been so one-sided
and I wouldn't argue I wouldn't argue
that they haven't been actually the most
compelling games they've just been like
three out of four games has just been
that little [ __ ] kick to the bull
there so so we'll see we'll see I had no
[ __ ] clue anymore I thought after two
and three I was like not only of the
Sharks going to beat the Blues they're
going to win the whole [ __ ] thing
because I'm not impressed with I mean I
like the lightning but they lost their
[ __ ] goaltender and I thought that
they was done I thought they was [ __ ]
done and now the sudden you know [ __ ]
Penguins won two in a row and then
[ __ ] Tampa cams al genius it both -
two - I swear to God if I didn't know
better that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] David
Stern is one of the goddamn NHL right
now seems like he wants both the series
to go seven games everybody makes that
[ __ ] money right they would never do
something like that
what are they the NFL um Jason um beer
company such a company such a goddamn
[ __ ] um I'm sort of paying attention to
the basketball I just don't have time
and I was really hoping that the
Cleveland Cavaliers were going to go
sixteen and oh and win a title on two
different levels one Cleveland would win
a title and all those sad sack Cleveland
fans could put with this stupid basset
hounds faces you know what I mean
Cleveland fans are so [ __ ] sad and so
many people just don't even give a [ __ ]
I mean they say just have the loneliest
look on their face at least when Boston
could win a World Series New York had
the decency to give a [ __ ] up the
trashes which was always funny to me
when you really thought about it's like
why are you wasting your time
they were like Walmart get mad at the
one mom-and-pop store up the [ __ ]
street because we were also trying to
sell rape right like why do you give a
[ __ ] but no one cares if I don't know
Ohio it's amazing the amount of
musicians fighters football coaches
entertainers the list of famous people
from Ohio might be the most
impressive out of all the 50 states and
they don't get any respect and but you
go out there it's just and I know it's
just kind of boring
Sabourin a state the [ __ ]
drive-through I don't know but they're
nice people but I don't I don't know if
I have sympathy for Cleveland fans as
much as they love Cleveland it's like
yeah well why don't you live there
nobody lives there it's like a [ __ ]
ghost town
I guess gradually it's coming back you
know that who gives a [ __ ] I just like
[ __ ] on people anguish so I wanted
to see them go 16 and all because it
would be great to see LeBron come back
you know after all the Cleveland fans
with burning burning it is Jersey when
he left you know I always said his
sister stupidest [ __ ] thing ever just
to go out and burn somebody's Jersey is
the newest cameras are filming you it's
like how [ __ ] old are you are you
really this emotionally invested in your
[ __ ] team I mean I love sports as
much as anybody
I remember when what's-his-face left Ray
Allen went to the heat and all these
Celtics fans were mad it's like dude
that's how we got him you know he
started with the Bucks and then II 41
once there's somebody a players of free
agent don't ever give you a heart to the
person telling me you can't go 100
percent in because they really you know
they got that [ __ ] they got that
wonder and I sometimes they stay like
Big Papi but most times you know they
come to come to town they pile on the
team they win a championship they start
acting like they [ __ ] Magic Johnson
and a Lakers or some [ __ ] Larry Bird you
know when they're really just you know
they're window-shopping throughout the
[ __ ] league
but anyways one of the cool things is
they actually went 60 nano will be so
[ __ ] up that the Golden State Warriors
right I'm assuming they make it to the
finals would go 73 and nine beating the
96 Bulls and having the greatest regular
season of all time and then losing the
championship game to me would have been
bug you know it's like the [ __ ] 2008
Patriots it's like they went 60 nano and
like I don't nobody gives a [ __ ]
nobody's ever going to give a [ __ ] about
that because all 16 and OH does is well
they
they want us next thing is did they wake
up did they run the table now and then
they lost the last one you know
something actually having lived through
that why would I root that for that for
Golden State
I don't know you notice did something
about LeBron that I actually feel bad
about the guy so bad for the guy I don't
wanted you know never seems to be on
strong footing with the crowd they
always seem to somehow not like the guy
and he's out there like Superman it'd be
nice who's kidding oh we brought her on
his agent brought her on him but that's
stupid [ __ ] press conference
you know doing this whole [ __ ] life
story and then you guys decided to take
my talents to South Beach you need me
safe he didn't say Miami that was one of
the worst worded [ __ ] statements ever
I've decided to take my talents to South
Beach it's like you're going to leave
the pound puppy looking sad sacks in
Cleveland freezing this [ __ ] balls up
you're going to talk about your talent
and then you're telling them that you go
into the beach you know what I don't
feel bad for I don't know I really like
LeBron so I would like to see LeBron win
one in Cleveland it's great he gets it
for the city but when he does win it if
he does I will really miss seeing those
sets at Cleveland fans they're just
funny to me I don't know what it is
about him I don't feel bad from and when
they complain I just left
I usually have empathy that's something
about him I don't
it's like Cubs Cubs fans some of them
out there still mad at me for that time
when I said white the White Sox fans
were real fans and I was just taking a
stab in the dark I was just [ __ ]
around because this guy was talking
about when the Bears beat the [ __ ] out
of the Patriots in the Super Bowl so I
just did the oldest trick in the book I
just went divide and conquer and I just
said that White Sox fans were better
than Cubs fans and it worked you know
what I mean years later somebody's gonna
lose you know through there in first
place was a flippin one of the worst
dependencies in the league
I got it ever just go to your stupid
game and take your [ __ ] shirt off and
act like you're in the Big Chill anyways
the Cubs actually win it that's that
that's the Theo Epstein [ __ ] saga you
know and me like what happened to the
Red Sox after 2004 was then all of a
sudden it was like you know when your
favorite band is just you know moving up
the ladder right there
so like gradually you know you know
they're playing clubs local areas and
they start going a little national then
they play bigger then they get all the
way up to their best out selling album
ever and what always happens when a band
that's been together for [ __ ] ten
years they make it to the mountaintop
what happened the whole thing implodes
everybody goes their separate ways
next to you no [ __ ] David Lee Roth is
singing just a gigolo right and Van
Halen is singing about dreams with the
[ __ ] Blue Angels whatever happened I
don't remember I try to block it out of
that [ __ ] crushed me were made from
egg broke up he was the perfect frontman
for that [ __ ] band I love Sammy Hagar
next name would come up anyways you guys
going to kill me but I completely forget
what I was [ __ ] for what the [ __ ] was
my point I really like explaining scroll
back up what the [ __ ] was I just talking
about Oh Theo Epstein
he's quite um Theo Epstein active like
2004 I think everybody wanted the credit
I think the [ __ ] ownership was like
now we're the reason the 86 years curse
ended and feels like well what about me
and then there was that weird thing
where he kind of went he like left for
like a week and I remember thinking like
[ __ ] why couldn't they just get along
you know here we go again and then he
came back and then I don't know when
everything imploded when I'm the [ __ ]
bed he ends up leaving he goes to the
tubs I thought he left then decided to
stay for a couple years I might be wrong
but he went with the Cubs and I think
that that was his ego thing and then the
Red Sox won at No 7 and in
2013 I believe and that was our [ __ ] you
field we can do without you so now I
think for his ego he's trying to become
the guy who ended the curse to the babe
and the curse of the goat and if he does
that I mean you'd have to say he's one
of the greatest whatever the [ __ ] his
positions he's at a GM I don't know what
he is
kirsta the goat is so [ __ ] stupid me
when we get your livestock off of the
[ __ ] field you know krysta the babe
was dumb enough it's just like now we
made a bad [ __ ] move we're not a good
franchise and we weren't a good
franchise we didn't make good decisions
the Yaquis god bless him did not make
good decisions the guy was a major
[ __ ] racist and just refused until
the last I don't we were we were the
last team to prilae admit you know I
guess people from other races are worthy
of looking at and by then would we even
then I mean we suck when it was just all
white people I mean I know what do you
gonna do um so anyways let's read some
of you had a questions here I know I'm
babbling this week this is I'm a little
outside my comfort zone without the
microphone the [ __ ] headsets oh sure
I'll be fixed by Thursday okay
vinyl hey Billy I was at Madison Square
Garden Show and I seem to remember you
mentioning releasing it releasing it on
vinyl is that still happening
interesting you should say that I have
the audio and I'm going through pictures
right now and I am telling you right now
I am going for big air on this one I am
releasing the entire [ __ ] show I'm
not editing anything out I was happy
from the second I got on to the second I
left was one of the greatest nights of
my stand-up life I'm so happy that I
have an audio recording of it
Cory Angelo one of the greatest
photographers I've met this business the
greatest I should say he took all the
pictures and I if I if I do this right
it's going to be a sick ass [ __ ]
record and I'm very very excited to do
it
I just have to do it the right way
what happens is if you want to get into
the [ __ ] of the business is this
happened what the one that I did at
Carnegie Hall what happens is is when
you put out a stand-up special you get
in business with so many like Comedy
Central or Netflix or HBO or whatever
you know usually built into the contract
is that you won't release any similar
material that bomb is special for a
specific period of time and you know I'm
probably going to another special in
November which you know I did Madison
Square Garden November of last year so
there's going to be enough overlap or
I'm going to have to wait I believe I'll
have to wait a little bit I'll try to
get around that collab negotiating yet
it would be nice about to get around and
be like look it's vinyl it's the [ __ ]
total comedy nerds this isn't going to
really but then of course you can't end
up uploading it everywhere because
everything has to be [ __ ] uploaded
and then be free I'm going to lose my
[ __ ] shirt on this but I don't give a
[ __ ] because I know there's people out
there that appreciate the vinyl and that
type of stuff and it's a really cool
[ __ ] thing to have and oh man I'm
going to spend some money on this I'm
really going to spend some money on this
I really want to do this as first
[ __ ] class as I can and I was
actually talking to somebody about it
the other night somebody who makes
records and he was showing me some of
the [ __ ] that he's done and I was really
impressed so I'm literally getting
excited talking about it so that's
definitely happening when I can actually
release the [ __ ] thing is a
completely different story so alright
basic training
Billy bloom you mentioned in a throwback
clip that you would only perform for the
troops in the Middle East if you went
through basic training and was taught
how to kill a man well at least how to
shoot a [ __ ] gun that's like my fear
I'm going into a [ __ ] war zone and
God forbid it gets overrun by a bunch of
lunatics and my bodyguard
one for me and he's laying on the ground
and there's his weapon and I'm like I
don't know how to work this standing
there like Bob Hope with a [ __ ]
putter you know I just you know I know
they and they always say this [ __ ] -
we've never lost anyone in all the wars
that we thought we've never lost anyone
and just like dude that's just like
saying like you know what my cars
running great you don't say [ __ ] like
then anyway he said was wondering if
that is true as it was when you said it
in 2008 I believed you're in better
shape these days and perhaps so is the
Middle East
love you love me um now yeah I think at
this point you know look through what I
saw over there like what I was first
thinking that that was back you know
when [ __ ] was really bad and like
contractors you know would had a rock an
issue and they would stop for half a
second to get it out and then they just
disappeared and then the next thing you
know they're getting their head sawed
off you know I mean what a [ __ ] way
to go I mean Jesus Christ you know what
I mean and I've also once one thing I
want the reasons why I've been any
success that I've had in life is I've
always understood what I suck at okay
and I know I am NOT a Marine you can
give me the camouflage [ __ ] you know the
dumb [ __ ] when people go out and go
[ __ ] do shows for the troops and they
take pictures of you sitting in a jet
like in a [ __ ] tank and you're
wearing a helmet you know it's a half a
second your ego so I could do this
no you can't see that takes a special
person to be able to do that and I know
that's not me who actually truly be
honest with you I wouldn't want to go
through basic training because I am a
[ __ ] lunatic to begin with and the
last thing I need to do is dehumanize
any more people in my [ __ ] up rings
yes I am afraid of both you know to go
down that rabbit hole of how [ __ ] I'm
not am I okay I like to feel that I'm a
mainstream psycho you know it's kind of
like my drinking like I know I drink way
too much but I have it
to control but I know a couple of
circumstance - I'm too vain to drink
myself to death but I could I could
definitely you know I know enough not I
knew enough not to [ __ ] with hard drugs
because I saw what they did to you know
like everybody I think everybody in my
country at this point for I hate to say
at this point you've lost somebody to
that and I've lost two people to friends
of mine outside of comedy and then
obviously a number of comedians too that
take a [ __ ] and both friends of mine and
comics that I was fans of in that type
of [ __ ] so I always knew not to [ __ ]
with that stuff but as far as going over
there yeah I would definitely do that I
would definitely do something like that
but you know when it was really [ __ ]
crazy over there and comics were telling
me they were they to do those military
landings where you like it's 38,000 feet
in a minute later you're on the ground
you know I mean it's scary enough
landing in San Diego I don't need
somebody possibly shooting at me yeah
and I'm just being [ __ ] honest you
know I mean so but at this point in I
have another problem Jesus I ever
[ __ ] go over there and something
happens to me and they play this [ __ ]
audio you know they're going to do with
all those [ __ ] things yeah you know
going to war is it know that the real
deal and I know I don't have that any
[ __ ] gold there with a Hawaiian shirt
play in that Sun going over there with
whoever the Marilyn Monroe is of the day
she's got this thing in you know happy
birthday mr. general or whatever the
[ __ ] goes I have no idea what happens on
those shows but I know likes like [ __ ]
Artie Lange went to like Artie Lange
went into this [ __ ] in like Afghanistan
like [ __ ] like crazy you would never
catch me through and that guy's got more
balls than than I would ever have no but
yeah I'll go to the big bass that
already has a best buy on it I'll go to
that one
whatever military base over there that
already has a monorail I'll go that one
maybe like an Orange Julius I'll check
that one out but I would definitely do
it without a doubt
alright name-dropping hey Bill I
listened to the podcast every week which
means my wife does as well she's not
another one of these I know women hate
me okay I watch in the hotel seeing this
guy's look I didn't know you were in
town like again I'm playing theater down
the street and he goes uh he goes I goes
yeah I'm definitely going to go goes you
know I'm gonna go against my girlfriend
hates you but I'm going to go it's just
like I I get it I get it I get it
I'm not going to change what the [ __ ] I
do though but I understand it here we go
all right
so okay here here it comes how long
before I get help how much I think I
read before I find out that she hates me
all right
last week you said you didn't want to
write you didn't want to name-drop
your friend's name in a band
they started my wife's down a path of
questioning and thought I'll quote her
who is build scared of you would think
he's still on a playground and waiting
to get beat up at the axe out of order
he's bill burr who's going to give him
[ __ ]
she has a good point I totally
understand why you do that but you'd
have to drop a dozen big names that
didn't even matter
but what but you have to drop a dozen
big names that didn't even matter into a
story every week for a year for anyone
to think of you as a name-dropper
you're the best come back to Rhode
Island you know why don't see what
because people who are in the public eye
it's like this sort of life there's a
there's an unwritten [ __ ] rule that
when you're hanging out with them you're
hanging out with them and then it
doesn't become a [ __ ] podcast story
you don't [ __ ] tweet about it you
know you know and you don't ask for a
picture because that's what their life
is and I know people that have [ __ ]
that up I got a buddy of mine all right
he was golfing and he got put in this
foursome with one of his favorite actors
and it turned out the actor was a fan
and
and they were having a great [ __ ]
time alright just shooting the [ __ ]
being normal and in the end the guy goes
yes hey man I'd love to come out to a
show and instead of saying alright give
me a number I'll text you next time I'm
in town he goes great he goes is it a is
it cool if I get a photo and he said the
guy's face just [ __ ] dropped and was
just like yeah yeah okay yeah let's do
it
I don't want to do that you looked like
I don't mind you know unless I'm trying
to get to a bar before it closes those
are only the times that I plug if you
know bothers me that somebody wants the
pictures it's way better somebody wants
a picture than nobody gives a [ __ ] but
I'm also at a cool level of just being
known
I'm known enough that I can sell tickets
on the road but like I can walk down the
street nobody [ __ ] with me right but
those people that are at that other
level
you know what I mean where they can't
leave the [ __ ] house you know if you
hang out with them you don't go blabbing
about it on a podcast it's uh it's to
put it bluntly it's really [ __ ] tacky
and it's not professional and not to
mention you come off like a
name-dropping [ __ ] you know I actually
had somebody do that three one time I
[ __ ] ignore this [ __ ] on me I'm not
somebody I was having this debate with
somebody I mean the [ __ ] writing
something about it afterwards it's like
oh you know I thought you're just a
couple of comics hanging out you know I
was just like and just I don't know I
just gross cuz all I thought like that
was [ __ ] gross good now I thought
that you know we actually would talk a
human being the human being and now
you're trying to get turn it into
something you know I don't know it's
gross that's why I don't do it alright
alright
wedding Shawn dear Billy [ __ ] ring
bearer Jesus he's I'm getting married
this Sabha and my fiance and I are
trying to figure out songs for the
wedding
you dig music what would you and the
lovely Mia
am ia is Neil with an N like Nancy the
lovely Mia suggests for our entrance and
first dance we appreciate your insight
oh my god I can't write but the person
just wrote Jesus Christ
easy what the homophobia there said go
[ __ ] yourself um I I don't fight you
yeah I listen to hair metal man you
don't listen to me I know something some
great white about white lion
one of those white bands there was white
snake white lion and great white that's
like when they had all the number bands
right Mary 3 and 4
311 sum 41 that out the [ __ ] art what
song should you come I would think the
song that both of you guys like I have
no idea
your wedding starts alright you coming
in I don't know I say something from Lou
Rawls lady love you know although he's
kind of suggesting an open relationship
a little bit if you really listen to it
anyway I don't [ __ ] know that's a
weird one I had no idea I don't know
what kind of music you're into how about
something from Cinderella speaking of
which from my generation I just found
out the drummer from Megadeth died last
night Nick Menza
yeah that's mega guest drummer Nick
Menza
collapses and dies on stage 51 [ __ ]
years old that's it
there's like three songs innings at that
place the baked potato which I have
never been to the legendary music venue
like if you ever come out to LA and you
want to go to a cool music venue and
possibly see some huge [ __ ] musician
just basically jamming with a bunch of
people from other bands or studio
musicians that's the place to go to I've
never been I don't know why I just
always end up
in busy we are going to do a stand-up
show but fortunately he does 51 then be
52 years old which is uh is way too
young in general but when there's going
to be 48 next month is pretty [ __ ]
scary lay off the [ __ ] chicken
quesadilla here we go French music
recommendation hey Geum Lee Rouge I know
you're working on your French skills and
you're always looking for music so I
thought I'd give you a tube of to fur
check out an artist named strim Mayer so
I say extra mega nope oh my god I'm an
idiot
oh I got him a [ __ ] idiot it stromae
and then it was - you're welcome
I thought that your was part of it
either one stromae ER but it's Treme
you're welcome
oh my god what a [ __ ] dope every time
I think I find the bottom of my
stupidity there's a whole nother floor
anyway he's from Belgium and his stuff
has a really diverse set of influence
influences but besides that the music is
amazing even if you have no idea what
the [ __ ] he's saying I'm not a native
French speaker wait he's from Belgium
but he sings in French anyways good but
my family spent some time in Belgium
when I was a kid I've forgotten a lot of
my French over the years and listening
to this is bringing it all back to me it
says bone bone shank
canard double and I know canard is duck
so co NN ard I don't know what that is
it probably says good luck [ __ ] I
have known dick or something I don't
know come back to New York City soon
that makes no sense to me that you were
in Belgium and you learned how to speak
speak French I thought you'd be able to
talk to Jean Claude Vaughn down the
muscles from Brussels right all right
girl wow this guy try to write girl is
[ __ ] with my head and she's so
[ __ ] with his head he wrote girls
girls
if [ __ ] with my head they're really
bad a few months
my waitress at a Mexican restaurant
caught my eye with her cheap smile and
warm personality I asked her out and
thing to go and break after two dates we
were having sex and I loved spending
time with her and making her left she's
also joining the Air Force and she used
to ask me advice because I'm in the
marine reserves I didn't see her during
her final week and late on Saturday
during my drill weekend she was texting
that she was a terrible person and she
was never going to amount to anything
sounds like she [ __ ] around with the
money I'm sorry that's just my paranoia
I consoled her and she sent a two-page
text while I was asleep
at 6:00 a.m. the next morning I woke up
to the text that read this has been
eating away at me and I had a few
glasses of wine and can't hold it in
there it comes on Wednesday I had lunch
with my old friend with benefits and I
ended up blowing him I'm so sorry
I liked you so much and I feel horrible
the next day I asked a few details about
the incident we are using your hand to
crank in the chef I asked a few
questions about the incident and said
she had a strange way of showing
affection towards me I told her I didn't
want to see her anymore and deleted all
of her contact into my info for my phone
and blocked her number perfect am I
being too hard is it really so hard to
not suck a dick I've never had the urge
she even told me not to cheat on her and
then does this I probably should have
seen it coming because apparently she'd
also had a threesome with two guys she
seemed so nice though this is the first
time I've been cheated on and it's
[ __ ] with my head I'm 23 this
shouldn't be that big of a deal but my
confidence took a serious blow here no
pun intended
you know that that happened to me at
least three times in my ways that I'm
aware of
women [ __ ] cheat - all right I mean
everybody knows that guys are dogs but
women do it [ __ ] it - all right and
um how many [ __ ] I know I get it you
just do the only reason right now where
you're questioning am I being so hard on
that's just your feelings talking
because you miss her but dude you did
the right thing the deleted her [ __ ] you
sold the [ __ ] up it's a big-time
self-esteem move and you're only 23
years old you got a bunch of great women
in your future I'm not saying [ __ ] her
as far as her as a person but just
forget her as far as what someone that
you can have a relationship with but you
know she's obviously working out some
stuff and uh you know she you know she's
on her path you're on your path and
you're not looking for that sounds like
it yeah just just move on you did the
right [ __ ] thing you know allow
yourself to be sad and go through the
[ __ ] and all that you know don't do the
dumb guy thing where you just try to
shut up your feelings go through the
feelings [ __ ] cry it out of you when
no one's around don't make it awkward
for other [ __ ] people and then uh you
know just don't [ __ ] with anybody for a
while you know figure out what the [ __ ]
you want to do next but don't go back to
her you can't go back ever yeah I
wouldn't do that plus you know she's
joining the [ __ ] Air Force you're
gonna Marines anyway you know you can't
tell me boy you guys try to go around
the [ __ ] world you're gonna meet all
kinds of beautiful women she has she
meant a long way she probably did you a
favor and I'll tell you right now that
is as positive as I can spin that
because I know that it sucks it sucks
you know what are you going to do
alright um but I wanted what was it
before I wrap this up here people keep
asking me about the European tour and
here's the thing I am not allowed to say
what the dates are it's definitely
happening but I can be vague about it at
this point I heard a rumor that it might
start the end of July
like the very end of July like maybe the
last day of July and I heard that it
might go
through I don't know mid-august like
well actually August 8 maybe to the 10th
it all [ __ ] depends
alright in the rumor is that it might
start in a city that in country that
rhymes with bubbling firelands and then
it might go to see that rhymes with hell
cast oh and then there's another one
hallway my Erland I'm not allowed to
release any of this information then I
might go to a pistol thing one can
fester England London England hands
hamster cam veterans and what the [ __ ]
kind of routing is that then I go up to
Edinboro hotland possible that might
that might be it I'm not allowed to say
but uh I don't know when we're going to
do this thing but I will tell you that I
thought I was going to Belgium and as of
right now if that's not on the list
which is really bugging me
because I really wanted to go there so
I'm hoping that maybe I can we'll see I
mean the amount of City that we got
offers from if I'm still going to remain
married I have to break it up into three
three tours so I think I'm going to do
this one and then maybe I'll do the
Scandinavian one with Belgium on that
one and then an Eastern European one I
don't know how long it's going to take
me to do all those but I definitely plan
on doing them and extremely excited
about getting over there there's a lot
of cities there that I've never played
to and I don't like I can't wait to get
over there plus you know it's going to
be great for me it's going to feel like
a summer vacation because we'll be done
writing all 10 episodes of ethics a
family so anyways that's uh that is the
podcast for this week once again thank
you to everybody came out to Calgary
Edmonton and Seattle tonight to spend a
great three-day run and to argue in I
got to take Seattle and all these areas
up here once you live out a [ __ ]
budget Matt it's just I always look down
as a plane landing or what if I live in
that house right [ __ ] there you know
somehow I was able to [ __ ] exist in
show business and not those out in LA
which I eventually maybe will be able to
do but then what I'm going to do I got
to be in the writers room eventually
I'll be that guy I'm going to be that
guy eventually I'm gonna be living next
to a [ __ ] rake in the middle of
nowhere and staring at walls drinking
myself to death
alright that's it everybody that's the
podcast I'm gonna watch the the Blues
game we'll see what happened here
and go [ __ ] yourselves and I will check
in on you on Thursday alright see you